[Musique]
tout d'abord je peux commencer par
vérifier quelque chose par
applaudissements qui parmi vous connais
quelqu'un cadres déjà eu un problème de
santé mentale
ce que je pensais parce que j'en ai
quand même vu deux ou trois qui n'ont
pas applaudi
je suis désolé mais chaque année plus
d'une personne sur dix développer une
maladie mentale
ça implique si vous n'avez pas applaudi
avec nous aujourd'hui et vous connaissez
au moins dix personnes et j'espère pour
vous vous applaudir et sûrement avec
nous l'année prochaine fois que
j'aimerais tout ce que vous preniez
quelques secondes juste pour penser à
cette personne et que vous écoutiez
extrêmement bien ce que je vais vous
dire je peux aider
j'ai accès à des informations qui vous
permettront d'être plus heureuse plus
épanouie qui pourront stopper sa
souffrance et et là je parle pas de
vagues promesses général ou de solution
magique non j'ai accès à des nouveaux
traitements à des nouvelles thérapies à
des solutions dont on sait qu'elles vont
pouvoir aider en fait j'ai non seulement
accès mais je le droit aujourd'hui de
les partager avec vous seulement voilà
je ferai pas
je pense la prefon ma vie qui me fait
détester par autant de personnes en
moins de 30 secondes fak avant que des
personnels ville genre là et là me
jettent des objets ou des pierres je
vais juste essayer de vous expliquer
pourquoi peut pas partager cette
information avec vous et pour ça j'ai
besoin de vous faire découvrir un peu
domaine de la recherche en santé mentale
et dans le domaine psychosocial de façon
générale alors de façon extrêmement
résumé j'ai une bonne et une mauvaise
nouvelle pour vous la bonne nouvelle
c'est que la recherche avance et là je
vais vous parler de quelque chose que
moi je trouve extraordinaire
tous les jours on a des millions de
chercheurs qui travaillent à mieux
comprendre le monde à mieux comprendre
l'univers mais aussi à mieux nous
comprendre nous à comprendre comment ils
milliards de neurones qui forment notre
cerveau arrive à se connecter qui a
donné naissance à nos idées et nos
pensées nos joies nos peines à tout ce
qui fait notre identité notre
personnalité à tout ce qui fait que nous
sommes nous on commence petit à petit à
comprendre comment cette chose
incroyable que notre cerveau fonctionne
et pour dire aussi parfois de
dysfonctionne on commence petit à petit
à comprendre ce qui donne naissance est
un malade mental qui a maintien ce qui
aggrave ce qui au contraire la soigne on
apprend petit à petit à mieux la
détecter à mieux soigner et ça c'est une
excellente nouvelle parce que ça veut
dire que chaque année chaque jour on
développe des informations qui peuvent
aider concrètement les millions
personnes
la mauvaise nouvelle c'est que les
personnes qui ont cette information et
ceux qui en ont besoin sont pas les
mêmes alors je sais ça paraît logique
voire même évident que l'information
devrait circuler dans l'air à d'autres
je suis totalement d'accord avec vous
mais c'est pas un cas en fait on dirait
qu'il ya une sorte de mur ou de
barrières entre les deux pour vous
donner une idée de l'ampleur de celui ci
on estime qu'à peine 14% de
l'information passe devient un autre et
que ça lui prend 10
est temps pour le faire alors je sais
que ça paraît être un chiffre mais ça ça
veut dire que 85% de notre recherche est
simplement perdu une recherche qui
contient des informations qui pourraient
aider des gens à éviter de souffrir et
parfois de mourir et pour moi c'est
capital que vous compreniez cette
situation parce que là je vous dis qu'il
ya un mur mais ce serait beaucoup plus
exact de vous dire qu'il ya un ensemble
de murs déjà un mur entre les chercheurs
et les décideurs politiques ceux qui
doivent déterminer notre système de
santé et de services sociaux ce qui
détermine quels sont les soins qui sont
donnés à la population sauf que comment
voulez prendre des décisions optimales
en n'ayant pas accès à toutes les
informations
une barrière entre les chercheurs et
intervenants et ça j'avoue que c'est un
aspect qui me touche particulièrement
parce que avant d'être chercheur je suis
intervenants et quand je travaille avec
quelqu'un
j'ai besoin d'information j'ai besoin de
savoir qu'est ce qui influence la santé
mentale tels sont les traitements qui
marchent quels sont les traitements qui
marchent pas l'information c'est mon
outil de travail et on enlève 85%
imaginez qu'il vienne chez votre médecin
qui arrive 85% de ces médicaments dit
qu'en plus je suis interdit d'utiliser
ceux des 17 dernières années
vous êtes peut-être beaucoup plus
confiant que moi comme personne mais moi
je sais que je perdrais très fortement
confiance et d'ailleurs c'est vrai que
nos services sont beaucoup moins
efficaces que ce qui pourrait être en
fait dans certains domaines on estime
c'est presque un tiers des personnes qui
reçoivent pas les traitements optimaux
dont ils auraient besoin est presque un
tiers qui reçoivent des traitements dont
ils n'auraient pas besoin
et finalement il ya une barrière entre
les spécialistes et le grand public vous
moi tout le monde alors déjà c'est un
gâchis incroyable pour la société parce
que tout ça c'est basé sur des fonds
publics
vous êtes en train de payer pour des
informations à quai vous n'avez pas
accès
mais surtout c'est une souffrance
incroyable pour les familles par exemple
moi je travaille régulièrement avec des
familles qui ont des enfants autistes
alors l'autisme c'est pas le trouble de
santé mentale ou plus répandue est un
peu plus d'un pour cent de la population
mais quand même c'est plus de 65000
personnes au québec plus de 70 millions
personnes dans le monde
et imaginez vous avez un enfant autiste
imaginez que vous sachiez pas quel qu
arrive pourquoi est-ce qu'ils aient agi
comme ça comment je peux aider
quelle est la cause imaginez qu'en
cherchant des informations sur internet
vous tombez sur un article qui dit que
c'est de votre faute
en tant que parent alors oui c'est
complètement faux et c'est absolument
ignobles que des gens osent encore dire
ça aujourd'hui mais c'est des croyances
qui circulent imaginez que vous visiez
ça que vous ayez aucune façon de savoir
si c'est vrai ou pas imaginer quelqu'un
dise moi j'ai une solution pour aider
ton enfant et qui vous disent que la
solution c'est la chélation alors pour
les personnes qu aux chances de ne pas
savoir ce que c'est que la création je
vais me limiter à dire que c'est une
méthode qui non seulement n'a jamais des
qui que ce soit dans le domaine de
l'autisme mais qui en plus a déjà causé
des morts imaginez que parce que vous
n'avez pas les bonnes informations sans
voix off ou de cuillé votre enfant c'est
des choses qui arrivent
imaginez vous sachiez même pas qu'ils
demandent et que vous sachiez que les
informations exactes quelque part
avec vous ils pas accès ah bon on me
dira que la solution semble extrêmement
facile il suffit de faire circuler
l'information de créer des ponts de cé
monde
oui d'ailleurs on le fait on fait des
conférences on publie des journaux on a
fait des bases données des sites web
on a créé des organisations comme unique
objectif de faciliter cette information
d'ailleurs tu es donner un on a même
créé un champ de recherche entier le
transfert de connaissances et
honnêtement vous imaginez même pas quel
point j'aimerais pouvoir vous dire ce
soir que aujourd'hui la science et la
situation est comme ça on a brisé tous
les murs et l'information circule encore
et encore des murs puis encore tellement
d'informations vitales
qu'ils se rendent pas auprès de ceux qui
en ont besoin pourquoi alors honnêtement
il ya des milliers de raisons pic
on pourrait en parler pendant des heures
mais déjà il ya un problème majeur
la masse d'informations pour donner une
idée chaque jour on estime qu'il ya plus
de 3000 articles qui sont publiés en
psychologie
alors quand je vous ai dit moi je suis
intervenants donc je me suis dit que
j'avais fait rien qu'à que si je
voudrais me tenir à jour juste en
autisme en me basant sur une seule
source
une seule langue for the past 18 heures
par jour à lire ça c'est la masse
d'informations si je voudrais me tenir à
jour en psychologie il faudrait que je
passe 1500 heures par jour et pourtant
je vous garantis que je skie vite ça
c'est aujourd'hui mais l'information ça
augmente on n'a pas les chiffres un
petit régime en médecine on estime que
d'ici 2020
l'information doublure 1 to et 73 jours
avec cette logique là ça s'est moins de
12 mois p j'aurais vraiment aimé vous
montrer ce que ça donnait dans six mois
une année deux ans mais pour faire cela
il aurait fallu que je bouge à peu près
tout et 8 de la bibliothèque mon
université qui étonnamment il n'était
pas super motivé pour ça mais tout ça
pour dire que c'est ça tout paradoxe on
a de la chance d'avoir tout cette
information dans toutes ces solutions
possibles à portée de main c'est juste
on peut pas suivre tranquillement je
peux pas suivre
en fait aucun groupe arrive à suivre
aucun organisme aucun groupe d'humains
va réussir à suivre la vitesse augmente
et moi je pensais bien que les uns
solution d'arrêter de se baser sur les
intelligences humaine et commencer à
penser aux intelligences artificielles
alors je sais quand je parle
d'intelligence artificielle vous pensé à
ça correct
désolé mais l'intelligence artificielle
c'est beaucoup plus faste ça ressemble
souvent à des grosses machines comme
celle là qui en fait fond des choses
qu'on considère comme intelligente donc
apprendre planifié percevoir mais
surtout résoudre des problèmes et vous
savez pas mais on a déjà tout autour de
vous alors bien sûr vous pouvez penser à
l'assistant personnel ou de votre
téléphone votre ordinateur comme syrie
watson on pourrait parler du guidage
d'avion de la surveillance des marchés
financiers du choix de votre prochain
film
la prévision météo et c'est normal parce
qu'au fond c'est une façon juste très
efficace de résoudre des problèmes il
n'y a aucune raison pour laquelle on
pourrait pas utiliser pour notre
problème de masse d'informations et
aucune raison pour laquelle on pourrait
pas enseigner un ordinateur à comprendre
leur santé mentale ou la psychologie ya
aucune raison pour laquelle est ce qu'on
pourra pas nous permettre de comprendre
nos questions et nous donner des
réponses et là imaginer que nos
décideurs aient accès à toutes les
informations pour pouvoir prendre des
décisions en connaissance de cause que
les intervenants puissent avoir accès à
toutes les informations pour faire le
travail
imaginez que vous si vous avez la
moindre question sur la santé mentale
puissiez jusqu'à poser à votre téléphone
à votre ordinateur et avoir des réponses
je sais que quand je dis ça ça paraît
impossible mais on n'est pas si loin
dans plein de domaines et la magie a
déjà dépassé humain par exemple en
médecine
la machine est déjà plus efficace que
nous pour détecter alzheimer le cancer
en radiologie
c'est vrai que domenico social on n'y
est pas encore et c'est normal il ya
plein de raisons et à sciences et
parfois moins coeur il ya plus de
facteurs à prendre en compte et plus de
différence d'une personne à l'autre
mais ça va changer en fait c'est en
train de changer
maintenant ici à montréal on est en
train de développer la première
intelligence artificielle qui phrase ça
en santé mentale et pour commencer au
nautisme en or si un jour vous avez un
enfant autiste
drake a posé la question à votre
téléphone mais intelligence artistes
vous répondra elle vous dira que
non c'est pas de votre faute que oui la
création c'est dangereux et vous dire si
jamais vous devez aller chez le médecin
avec votre enfant mais et vous dirai
comment faire pour ça se passe bien elle
vous dira qu est-ce que d'autres
personnes ont fait qu'est-ce que les
autres parents ont fait est ce que c'est
un marché
alors c'est vrai que notre prototype
fera pas tout ça mais c'est vers ça
qu'on 120 en fait on serait peut-être
même beaucoup plus loin parce que la
fopac d'autisme et j'aurais pu parler de
l'anxiété de la dépression de la
schizophrénie d'alzheimer imaginez qu
enfin toutes ces informations soient
disponibles savez je vous ai dit au
début que je voudrais pas une
information dont vous avez besoin
j'espère honnêtement que vous aurez
compris que c'est pas parce que j'ai une
tendance sadique ou parce que je fais
pas d'effort je fais partie des gens
qu'on décide de consacrer leur vie à
essayer de résoudre ce problème c'est
juste que j'y arrive pas l'information
dont vous avez besoin
pas comme chercher une aiguille dans une
botte de foin c'est comme chercher une
aiguille dans un champs remplis
d'aiguilhe identique
j'y arrive pas mes parents je peux
construire quelqu'un qui oui y arrivera
et c'est ça le point fondamental
je pourrais dire on a tous une chance
sur 10 l'année prochaine de développer
une maladie mentale
et quand ça nous arrivera est-ce qu'on
veut qu'une voie soit là pour nous
répondre
si la réponse est oui il faut commencer
à construire tout de suite alors
renseignez vous soutenez les chercheurs
du domaine participer à nos bêta testing
dites-nous les informations dont vous
avez besoin
bref aidez nous à vous donner accès à
l'information qui vous revient merci
[Applaudissements]